the small medieval town of Korea with
its impressive fortress is surrounded by
the foothills of the Swiss Alps the name
grill comes from the town's emblem the
crane all igloo in French glare is home
to just over 2,000 people but every year
around a million tourists come to the
home of the famous cheese I've dated so
many times I really tired that we can
buy in Brazil mmo-champion I love a
strong cheese like a mature kuya if you
have tyree will definitely eat some
cheese the first recorded mention of
trees production in the area of clear
dates back to 1115 the cheese has borne
the town's name since 1602
cybelline Escoffier runs a delicatessen
and knows all about cheese I love so
colossally Sally so this is a media
mature clear that's our second martyrs
cheese the first one is the mark layer
which has had four to five months to
mature and doesn't have a strong taste
with em opelu newseum salami Sally yella
dish while this media mature cheese has
been stored for six to eight months and
has a more pronounced salty taste you
sell it up Oakland on sea cows of the
hosting breed graze on the hills
surrounding the town in all the contour
of people has 51 Alpine cheese Darius
that produce per year using traditional
methods
the belayer family's dairy is at an
altitude of 1600 meters they have a herd
of just over 50 cows BRP lair works all
hours to make the cheese first the milk
is gently heated in a huge copper that
as it thickens he stirs it with two
wooden scoops said to do their faucet
yeah the beginning is the most important
phase in the production hub we got these
scoops ensure that the mixture divides
and the Kurds separate out there call it
compile a pot not nutrient
the cheese is now beginning to take
shape the best way to test its
consistency is by hand créer is always
made with unpasteurized milk wheezing 1k
do you see you that's a good quality I
always check it by hand we don't have
any technical equipment here to check
things we rely totally on our senses
make no sense hello is your son here you
can already feel how soft it is look at
how the Kurds have separated yeah sve
more technology and a lot more vats can
be found at another dairy right near
clear unlike the Alpine dairies this
place is open to the public who can
watch the production process from a
gallery the rounds of cheese are left to
mature at 13 degrees Celsius each one
comes with a manufacturers stamp
allowing customers to get back to the
producer if they have a complaint yeah
Luna mejor left the cheese bears the
number of the dairy that's here your
horse is a demo see the number will also
be on the packaging later yeah yeah
we'll see shucks so if someone buys this
clear in Germany oh good they can enter
the number online it values your hand
find out which dairy the cheese that
they're eating comes from Lulu you could
go Sam ad thick the restaurant next door
offers a wide range of cheese dishes
like risotto with cheese or Swiss potato
rosti with Pierre and of course cheese
fondue
it was at the 13th century castle ink
layer that exporting the cheese first
became a serious business after the
original Creole counts the castle became
home to the pre bull bailiffs they had
the cheese transported to Lake Geneva
and sent from there all over the world
earning handsomely in the process today
the cheese is still a standard feature
at the castle I don't you see easily
pick me girl people people often bring
their glia sandwiches and have a picnic
here or bring a piece of cheese that
they bought in town that's phoned okay
we also organize small parties with
cheese fondue for our guests on Castle
for those of you did only the milk from
cows grazed on the meadows of clear is
used for the famous delicacy which has
won international awards as the world's
best cheese
you